i don't know where the hell he could be
was that his motorbike or no no do you
think he would hide back there i don't
know
listen
there's a lot of things going on to my
mind right now
like i have give all my life to my baby
brother
never ask anything back
so don't treat me like that
dude let's talk for a minute
tell me what's going on love
i just cannot handle it anymore
i
try to hold on and be strong as long as
i can once a day it's just one
it's wrong
[Music]
it's gonna be okay
[Music]
is
can't
understand it
we'll go back to the house
you can rest
he'll eventually turn up and we can talk
to him in the morning i don't want to
talk to him anymore
my mentor cannot
i've never seen annie like this ever
she doesn't let out her emotion it's not
a cultural norm but jordan is pushing
her limits
in the ways i've never seen before
i never planned to get the kids to
america being this difficult i knew it
would have its challenges but i never
thought it would break any
[Music]
you